i said what i said and boy i heard what
you said
my god
how could i not dave chappelle speaks
out and he's not backing down the
comedian just shared his reaction to
backlash she's facing following
controversial comments he made about the
lgbtq plus community in his latest
netflix special the closer it's been
said in the press
that i was invited to speak with
transgender employees at netflix and i
refused
that it's not true
if they had invited me i would have
accepted it although i am confused about
what we are speaking about since the
specials released there have been
protests and netflix employee walkouts i
wanted to make this video to say thank
you and to express my deep gratitude to
every single one of you in the trans
non-binary intersex communities of
netflix and in a video posted to
instagram monday chappelle insists that
the real issue isn't between him and the
transgender community you said you want
a safe working environment at netflix
well it seems like i'm the only one that
can't go to the office anymore i want
everyone in this audience to know
that even though the media frames us
that it's me versus that community
that is not what it is
do not blame the lbgtq community for any
of
this
this has nothing to do with them it's
about corporate interest and what i can
say
and what i cannot say the controversy
all began when the closure hit netflix
earlier this month comedians have a
responsibility
to speak recklessly
sometimes the funniest thing to say is
maybe
remember i'm not saying it to be mean
i'm saying it because it's funny in the
special chapel made derogatory comments
about gender and even identified himself
as team turf which stands for trans
exclusionary radical feminists an
ideology that excludes trans women
celebrities many made famous by netflix
spoke out in support of trans talent at
the streamer after the special's launch
netflix trans non-binary intersex family
i love you so much i am sending you so
much love and solidarity and just
sending you so much gratitude for the
work that you continually do the work
that folks see the work that folks don't
see
to create a world that is more equitable
and fair and to ultimately achieve lgbtq
liberation as more feedback flowed in
online the comedians rep told et he's
open to speaking to those who work at
netflix and are upset by his jokes
saying quote dave stands by his art both
sides of the street are talking and dave
is listening at some point when everyone
is open i'm sure our communities will
come together
for the record
and i need you to know this
everyone i know from that community has
been nothing but loving and supporting
so i don't know what all this nonsense
is about chappelle reiterated that
invitation in his video but it comes
with a few conditions to the transgender
community i'm more than willing
to give you an audience
she will not summon me
i am not bending to anybody's demands
and if you want to meet with me i'd be
more than willing to but i have some
conditions
first of all
you cannot come
if you have not watched my special from
beginning to end am i canceled or not
then let's go thank you very much and
good night chappelle turned off comments
on the clip
you